[Music]
and we are live
hi everyone
welcome welcome to uh to the first
episode of a hugging cast
I see we already have 23 of you here
uh we're gonna take it easy for a couple
minutes to make sure that people have
time to join in
um so if you if you just get here uh
please leave a comment in the chat uh
and then we can show it just like that
thanks David thanks David for joining
yeah we're super excited also about uh
today's fighting guys it's very much an
experiment uh we're it's our first
edition it'll probably go horribly wrong
so thanks for being part of that but if
it goes well then we'll do a lot more uh
audits so definitely let us know
[Music]
and we got Aaron Aaron hi hi uh tell us
also tell us where where you're from uh
where you're joining this uh this hiking
cast from
foreign
kids welcome welcome yes we're very
excited about the first edition uh
hopefully it'll be fun for everybody we
got Luis in the house hi Lewis
thank you for joining where are you guys
all uh joining from
[Music]
okay so we got
Aaron from Oakland well hello I um I did
not wear I was tempted to wear my
Warriors hat today but uh I guess uh I
guess I went for for the classic you
know uh I want to respect the Sacramento
fam uh we got Lance from Atlanta
they will work on San Francisco
yes Germany is in the house
hi Christoph yeah
we got
stem from Boston welcome Lynette from
Seattle
more Germany you do um
there there are field Bots come on
friends in here come on enough
we got Toronto
Toronto all right let's go
[Music]
awesome
yes David you can claim Australia of
course so as I said uh welcome everybody
this is the first edition of the Hagen
cast uh if it works well we'll do more
if it's this whole failure well sorry
about that
um and uh so what we want this to be and
let me turn off that music maybe that'll
help a little bit what we really want
this to be is sort of a cross between a
podcast and a webinar
um kind of a podcast in the sense that
we want to tell you about all the
exciting new developments that are
happening uh in the beautiful world of
Open Source Ai and we know there's a lot
so hopefully we can distill it down for
you guys and we also want this to be a
sort of a webinar which is we want to
teach you practical things that you can
use in your day-to-day work and walk
away with these things
um and uh so yeah and I think I I set
this up to be like one hour long uh I
probably just fumble like we really want
this to be short and sweet we know you
guys all have work to go back to so
we'll try to make it like 30 minutes but
of course there's lots of live Demos in
there so let's see how good uh and yeah
if you have questions you know you can
keep us you can keep us online for a
little while so yeah we'll uh we'll keep
it short but we'll be happy to have a
lot of questions so keep us busy you can
keep them coming in the chat please
and that's the exciting thing about the
webinar that is all about interacting
with the live audience so I'm really
excited to get your questions in the
chat and we'll save some time at the end
to make sure that uh we uh pick them and
answer them yes
all right
um so
um to introduce myself I'm sorry I'm
Jeff poulier I'm the product team here
at hagging face based out of San
Francisco and joining me today my
co-conspirators for the hugging cast the
cast of the hugging cast the the heroes
of the demos with the demos uh we got
Phillip Schmidt and Julian where's the
hi everyone
laughs
all right well let's start a little bit
with uh news uh and so on news
um I guess the the first thing that uh
people wanted to hear about is what we
uh at heightened face released uh
yesterday uh which is a new uh
application called uh hugging chat and
so I want to tell you all about hiking
shot to make sure you understand what it
is what it's not uh and what it really
means for you
so hugging chat is uh sort of the uh
proof that
um you can create and use a chat GPT
like experience using only open source
an open source model with an open source
data set using an application a UI that
is also open source and that's really
what hugging chat is uh today let me
show it to you if you haven't seen it
already
uh share screen
hugging chat there you go hopefully you
can see that so a little bit of a PSA
like before you get in there uh you
gotta understand that this is really a
demo application it's meant for you to
understand like what is possible uh and
the models uh the models do some amazing
things uh they're they're really amazing
in ways that are unexpected and are also
terrible in like very uh expecting uh in
ways that you can really expect right
they're terrible at math they will make
things up uh and they will reflect the
data that they are being trained on like
the good news is that this is an open
source model so you can look at the
training data you can look at the model
um and uh and understand how it works
all right so don't use this for high
stakes decisions or to do advice don't
let models take the decisions
um on behalf of humans that's that's
like the general uh guideline so here's
hugging chat
um it is interacting with an assistant
uh model an open source assistant model
using a natural conversational interface
a chat interface you're all familiar uh
with
um so it really makes those models
accessible to everyone speaking about
the model so the hiking chat release is
not about the model but the model that
is available today is the best uh open
model that we had today for a
conversational experience in some model
from the open Assistant organization
uh so open assistant is an amazing
organization
um that is dedicated to building uh open
source uh AI for everybody that released
multiple models we've been collaborating
uh with them uh and what's super
exciting about it is that anybody in the
world can come and contribute uh some
human feedback to get the models better
over time and all that data is made
available as open source on hugging
phase for the whole Community to build
great great models so super happy to
have open assistance model sort of power
the experience that you can interact
with and of course because it's open
source you can check out the model page
the model that is currently used will be
sort of putting uh behind hugging chats
the the latest and best models that are
available
um and of course you can look at the
data set page for that model uh with
just a click so you can see exactly what
went uh into it so that's what uh
hugging chat uh is like again it's all
about uh the application uh what we
released yesterday and the application
itself is open source so what that means
is that you now have proof that you can
create a chat GPT like experience using
your data using your model fine tuning
open source models and do everything
with open source and build that in-house
so I think that's super super exciting
but yeah let's do a little demo that
will probably go horribly wrong so
here's my uh here's my uh conversation
starter I have a llama in my backyard I
want to know it's weights what should I
do explain step by step
um
yeah I guess why we are waiting for
traffic we got a question
um Jeff can we access the model through
an API as well or is the chat like uid
only only place
so the model yes of course uh the model
is available on hugging face it's like
one click within a hugging chat
um and we can put the URL in the banner
um so the model is accessible right
there and like any model on a hugging
face it's available to be queried via
API we have a free service to do
experimentation a low volume that's
called the inference API and so just
like you can interact with the model on
the model page you can interact it
programmatically and then of course we
have our production solution to deploy
models that's called inference endpoints
where you will take that model and
deploy it on dedicated infrastructure so
it works for you and you have the right
latency and throughput to poor
applications so that's these are the
ways that you can do and then of course
we have multiple deployment options
wherever you you work from so if you're
working in AWS we have a great way for
you to use those models leveraging
sagemaker where we have open source
solutions for you to take any of the
models and there's like over 180 000 now
take any of those models and then have
them deployed very easily on sagemaker
and points uh using our deep learning
containers and inference locate Etc we
make it super easy yeah and I think it's
it's worth you know saying that all the
bits and pieces
are actually open source right so the
model as you said is available the UI is
available if you uh if you click through
the links in in the chat you'll see uh
in in hugging chat you'll see the the
location on that I think the inference
server is actually
um is actually open source right as well
so you can take all the building blocks
and and you could run this uh even
on-prem if you wanted right yeah and
like we got a great follow-up question
which I think we should also like um
include yet like so the model we
currently run in hiking chat is like
based on a llama with like some X all
weights so it is basically what you find
on the high invest Hub on not the Llama
weights it's basically the difference
between the original weights and the
fine-tuned weights and you need access
to the Llama weights and llama is like
like sadly not the easiest model in
terms of Licensing so you cannot use it
for commercial use cases but you can use
it for research use cases where hiking
chat Falls underneath so the idea really
here is not to have like uh like
commercial solution to like chat and
create money it's really to provide
access to see where we currently are in
terms of Open Source and it's probably
just the beginning like the the open
Assistant organization released the
model I think like 10 days from from now
like so it's like available 10 days and
we have like a lot of other initiatives
like retraining or recreating yeah llama
type models with like the the red pajama
from together and I'm like expecting
similar performance and ways we can
commercially use within the next two two
months probably
yeah so how do you weigh a llama do you
get a good answer I didn't get an answer
uh but the answer was actually a little
long like I'm not gonna bother uh read
it all uh so
if you have a llama you can go and read
and try but well then I asked uh you
know as the the model to do this in one
paragraph you know so that's much better
okay so to find your llama's exact
weight follow these steps firstly locate
a suitable livestock scale which has
been verified work accurately by
checking specifications obtaining it
from a reliable source next of course
laser scale on flag ground within easy
reach of the Llama encourage the Llama
into position by utilizing tempting
treats and awful rewards that's very
specific okay once the Llama is standing
still on the scale record the reading
and take note of any changes to maintain
a record of the llamas growing Trend
over time so that's how you get the
Llama weights and yes very important
dilemma weights are for research search
purposes only the release of hugging
chat is all about the UI the UI is open
source that means you can use it with
any uh sort of model and we're very
excited to see truly permissible models
come out from the community uh that we
will be happy to uh to offer directly
through hugging chat for people to
interact with
all right that's sort of what I wanted
to uh to say uh about hugging chats uh
don't use it for math uh it's terrible I
tried it with my kids they were not
impressed uh but uh it is a lot of fun I
don't know if you guys had some good uh
good interactions with the with uh with
the app
we got another great question from
Christoph will it be possible to provide
human feedback via the hiking chat user
interface Jeff that's that's a a great
question and uh as it said like in the
in the little Banner this is v0 uh right
so v0 we have a lot of feature requests
coming and yes of course like being able
to provide feedback uh is uh is a great
uh feature that we want to add uh
because this feedback is so valuable for
the community uh it's uh one of the most
amazing things about the open Assistant
project right that's a whole Community
from all over the world came together to
contribute uh human feedback to build a
great model and now with hiking chat you
can see the progress that's been
achieved through to through that so yes
we want to add the the possibility to
build more feedback to contribute back
to the to the model uh to the model
authors uh but today we're not yeah I
was just I was just adding uh yeah I was
just gonna add I think it's it's the
right time to say uh there is a privacy
policy I could I would encourage
everybody to read it
um we want to be crystal clear on the
fact that we don't store in or or use
anything for any kind of TR training
activity or data sharing or anything
like that
um you know so we've I guess we've all
seen what happened with other chat Bots
and we're definitely trying to be very
clean and very transparent on privacy
and and things like that so um if we add
a a human feedback button
um and I I think it's it's valuable we
should we should have it we should also
be very clear on what happens when you
give that feedback and what do we do
with it and
Etc do what kind of settings do we have
to you know opt-in and opt out
um and so on so until that stuff is
clear you know we will probably won't
add anything so uh so for now so then
you can you can say we are doing open AI
development
no I I refrained from saying that
because I've got enough friends as it is
um but of course I I was you know I was
referring to
previous mistakes
um whether they were deliberate or or
not but we're trying to to follow our
you know philosophy of being friendly
and transparent
all right so I wanna I wanna switch to
the the demo part of uh of this uh
hiking cast uh episode and as we put in
the notes we have some amazing new
things that we want to share with you
that are coming from uh our partnership
uh with AWS so you may or may not know
but we've been working with ideas for
over two years now uh to make it super
easy to use hiking face models data sets
libraries within AWS we've built some
amazing experiences within sagemaker to
make that possible so you can do
training of hugging face models you can
do deployments of hiking face models
super easily with deep learning
container and recently we sort of
doubled down uh on our relationship and
one of the main benefits you're gonna
get from that is our collaboration
around Hardware so now we're really
making it easy from the hardware layer
all the way up to the manage platform
form layer to use a hiking face within
AWS and so that means getting getting
all the benefits of the accelerations of
the custom Hardware that AWS makes
available and so it means the trainium
instance that's dedicated to training
and it means the inferentia and now the
new inferential instance that is uh very
very efficient to run run models um so
we're going to focus a lot of the demos
today around this because I think it can
really save a lot of money for everybody
who does like some production work
and yeah today I'm excited to have
Philip and Julian their Heroes of the
demos uh show you uh how we're big fans
you know uh you know and and
Philip and myself you know I don't want
to speak for affiliate but we've spoken
enough I think we're big fans of the AI
accelerators and and we're really really
happy to to show you that stuff today we
think it's really you know it is
extremely valuable and it's it's really
helping speed up the workflows in ways
that I don't think we even thought was
possible like when we run the numbers
we're like really uh like double
checking and and yes that's that what
you see what you're going to see here is
is real so uh yeah just feel if I you
know
show us the training bit I see your your
your flying uh Optimum you're on page
like can you make it a little bit bigger
and like what is this thing
yes so I'm currently on the hiking face
Hub on the documentation uh where we
added today a new tile for Optimum
neuron and I'm not sure how familiar you
are with the the optimum like framework
Family itself so Optimum is an extension
to high in Phase Transformers and
diffusers to run our models on dedicated
accelerators and like the newest
addition to the family is Optimum neuron
and which is going to be dedicated and
it's dedicated to running
um improved training on the AWS trainium
instance and of course inference on
inferentia and inferentia too and it's
basically like the first initial version
and we are going to show you today um
how you can like super easily train
um a bird Mobile on a trainum instance
and then tune in will show you how fast
you can like make this model with like
basically one one line of code and the
the optimum neuron documentation is
going to be really the place for
everything related about hiking phase
and the AWS accelerators we are going to
add more tutorials on how to do certain
things we have guides to help you better
understand how everything works behind
the scenes and then of course to to to
get you started and since we are like
doing it in enhanced on fashion we
really like try out if I can subscribe
to an aim I run Optimum neuron trainer
Bird model and stop the instance again
with hopefully under five minutes so if
you go to the installation section you
can see that Optimum is like a python
package and you can like install it with
PIV install Optimum neuron but what we
have done and created is something
called in deep learning Ami which is an
um machine image so Ami stands for
Amazon machine image which is basically
a pre-baked virtual machine with all of
the required libraries to run
Transformers and diffuses workloads and
the the Ami is completely free so the
the 1. 33 44 cents you see here is
really for the instance price and the
Ami is completely free of charge
and it's a Marketplace offering so you
go to the link
um click on subscribe
and continue to launch here again you
can see the pricing is really only for
the infrastructure where we have one TRN
one two weeks large which is basically
the the smaller instance type of the
adrenium family there's also a TRN a 32x
large which comes with eight times more
or even 16 16 times more compute and we
see a monthly estimate how much it would
cost if we run these things
yeah yeah nice thank you
all right then let's continue to launch
and what what's super cool about the
marketplace is that you don't need to go
through like the ec2 Management console
and launch it you can really launch your
instance from the website directly or of
course through like the ec2 but we want
to try it out launching it directly from
the
um Amazon Marketplace we can select our
instance type um I guess okay sadly you
cannot see the drop down but in there
you could like switch between the two
weeks large the 32x large or then even
go to like influencia too we have our
VPC let's keep it standard we select a
Security Group which has SSH access and
we use uh key to login and then I click
launch and we encounter internal issues
oh not available in the subnet let's
switch it to let's try eight
let's launch again
perfect
it worked and we can now jump to the ec2
console
to hopefully see our instance
and with uh no no so Philip the trainium
instances are available in Us East one
and U.S West 2 correct yes yeah
currently they are available there um
influencia 2 is also available in the
same region yes in uh and influential
two is also available in U.S east 2 and
hopefully they they will like add Europe
um yes okay so we are currently on the
ec2 Management console and we can like
um directly like SSH into it through the
processor using the ec2 instance connect
I would definitely recommend you not
doing it if you are trying it yourself
and use like your local terminal but
this makes it easier for us to not need
to switch between
um different windows
so let's see if we click on connect and
already can establish a connection
uh no
still still booting up and needs a few
minutes
Japanese okay got it let me switch so I
am now logged into our trainium instance
I can run a neuron LS command which is
basically a similar command to like yeah
it shows you the our nylon course
similar to probably Nvidia SMI if you
run on Nvidia or GPU instances
can you make it a bit bigger yep of
course
it should be a bit too big I think it's
fine what's super cool about the Ami is
that it not only comes with all of the
hugging face Library installs it called
comes also with a folder or directory
called how you face Lauren examples and
if we go into it we can see that the
instance comes with
nine different examples scripts for you
to like immediately run and get started
and what we are going to do I will like
copy my command I have prepared from the
blog post we shared yesterday is that we
are going to use torch run to leverage
our two neuron costs so as you have seen
in the neuron LS command we have two
accelerators in our instance so we want
to use distributed training therefore we
use torch run we Define our two
accelerators and then we run from the
high investment samples the text
specification example which includes the
run one run clue script which is
basically similar to when you know the
Transformers examples from the GitHub
repository modified to to use the new uh
trainium trainer we Define okay we want
to use bird based we use the motion data
set which is a sentiment classification
data set with six different emotions we
want to do training we want to do evil
we also want to use mixed position
um we have a batch size of 16 a learning
rate and
and free epochs let's
run it and let's see how our training
will go the last time we rented it it
took around two and two and a half
minutes so we have some some time to
answer some questions
so we got one from Christoph uh which is
is there a comparable serverless GPU
support on AWS compared to banana
So currently the AWS offerings like AWS
Lambda or fargate are not supporting
gpus
um which is not directly a serverless
offering but what we are building with
inference endpoints currently is to add
scale to zero capabilities so as Jeff
mentioned uh in the beginning inference
endpoints is our production solution to
quickly and easily deploy Transformer
models and currently we are not able to
scale to zero but that's a feature the
team team is working on you clearly can
pause your endpoint but that's like a
manual action and hopefully within the
next few weeks we will have a feature to
like automatically scale down to zero
your compute when you are not receiving
interest which is then like some kind of
a serverless but not really since it's
like a still managed instance and you
select like which instance you want to
run on
but it's able to scale down to zero to
like not have any any costs securing for
you
awesome
if any more questions I don't hesitate
push them in the chat uh while the
machine is working we can address them
Luis has one for us uh can we run
compute on our own AWS account
so I guess there's two parts to that
right so everything that you're doing
here Philip is of course on your AWS
account and you can do that right now
following the steps of the optimum
neuron documentation but influence you
are asking about uh about inference
endpoints
uh inference endpoints uh is a hiking
phase service where we manage the
efficient infrastructure uh you can of
course select uh it will use the region
you want the instance type that you want
um and then the compute is using uh is
managed basically by hacking face we do
have a very cool feature uh that's
um a setting when you go to create an
endpoint you can select it to be private
and what that does is uh it leverages
the the private link feature of AWS so
that there is a direct direct connection
between your VPC and the endpoint that
will manage for you so that the data
never goes onto the internet so that's
the closest thing to running it within
your own address account but of course
like the whole point of inference
endpoints that you don't have to manage
it
um
regaf can this be easily extended to
training large language models with PFT
yeah that that's a great question so
currently the the trainium instances and
the trainium trainer are not yet ready
for model parallelism so that makes it
um quite hard to to run like huge models
for for training but the team is working
on like supporting uh fstp for like full
Shadow data parallel to like distribute
your model across different devices and
then you you will be able to to run
um model parallelism and like training
llms using path since like path only
like switches in like
um different layers or just add some new
tokens for for prompt tuning
awesome and let me know if you want me
to stop the questions I got one more
from Miguel
um how can we help to this project as a
software developer so Optimum neuron
like everything that's uh uh Philip is
using right now is open source and like
every open source project in the uh
hugging phase
um uh GitHub like it's open for people
to inspect and use and contribute to we
also have a new category within the
hiking face Forum on discussed at
hikingface.co which is where we uh
interact with the community ask
questions solve problems
um specifically for a neuron and using
trainium and inferentia so that's
another way that you can contribute if
you don't want to contribute code you
can help people out by showing them how
they can be successful answering their
questions
um I get another question from xiam
which is like is this only for inference
no so so what we are currently running
on the trainium instance which now runs
like with with some slow start we can
like see almost 11 iterations per second
which is crazy you can like see how fast
it's like going through through like
those those three epochs on our build
model the trainium instance is built for
training which makes it of course the
best use case to to run training but on
the other side we have the influential
instance family which is really built
for inference and inferentia 2 is also
now available in GA so you can like go
to your ec2 console and start an
inferentia instance using the the
hanging phase Ami and we also
um have already part of the optimum
library in exporter so you can export a
high invest Transformer models to be
um inferential compatible and then run
inference on them and
um yeah that that that's how you get
like started with inference
thanks Philip I got one more from soil
so it doesn't support both potential
flow and Pi torch uh the demo is in
pytorch yeah so so currently we are only
supporting pythons uh with hopefully
tensorflow support coming
um later the year we aren't sure yet
when it's going to be ready since like
the the majority usage we see um is on
on Pi torch
um is there like something you can like
share a bit more
um if you would be interested in
tensorflow use case or usage and if so
like why that I guess will help us
better understand and prioritize
so maybe we should add the the AWS SDK
that uh that that
um that we use to to to train and uh and
and influence with uh training and
inferential does support uh tensorflow
and pytorch
so um I'll share the link in the in the
chat but for now as Philip said you know
the the most popular models are are
partorch and so that's obviously the
first uh the first step along the way
but let me share the the link here and
you can read more about that
yes and while we were speaking okay our
training is done and we are now like
running the evaluation it it had a slow
start and potentially it was like due to
compilation so something we like
completely haven't talked about it yet
and like didn't show you so far it's
like normally when you train a model on
a trainum instance you first need to
compile your model which can take up to
20 minutes but what we have done with
Optimum neuron is to build a trainum
cash or training model cash which is
powered and hosted by the hiking face
Hub which already includes popular
Transformer models so instead of the
needs when you run a training on like
bird you don't need to like run this
compilation we basically check inside
Optimum neuron if there's already a
cached version of your model and your
configuration and if so we pull it from
The Hub and your training starts
immediately and that that's also
something we currently see here is that
okay this dot dot indicate okay the
configuration wasn't completely cached
and we might need to run some
pre-compilation steps and we are like
really working hard on like having all
of the popular configurations available
to like really like improve and
accelerate your your training time and
not have you like wait 10-15 minutes for
like the most popular models
we're very proud of this feature uh it's
uh it's something that has never been
available at all
um only WS right I mean it's never been
part of sagemaker it's never been part
of anything it's never been part of the
SDK and so very very happy that we could
be the first to implement this and save
you a whole bunch of uh a whole bunch of
time for every training job so very cool
wait so what does that mean in practice
like so if I take a quintessential sort
of hiding face model
um like the caching system like I go
from we're saying like 25 minutes to to
what
so you eliminate you completely
eliminate the need to recompile the
model every time and because the way
this happens it recompiles it on the so
it downloads the model from The Hub it
compiles it locally on the instance and
it normally you know it saves it to
slash VAR slash TMP blah blah blah so if
you run another training job right away
on the same instance of course you have
that local cache but
generally you don't keep your trainium
instances up and running when and up and
not running I should say so so you'll
shut down the instance and then you fire
up another instance just like Philip did
and it doesn't have the the cash for all
the previous compilation jobs and so by
moving the cache to the hub
uh we have this you know persistent
cache of compiled models that will keep
growing and that the community can use
and so now when you as Philip
demonstrated when you launch the
training job it's going to go and check
that Hub repo
and find oh okay so I've got bird base
pre-compiled in the right configuration
I'm going to download it and start
training right away and uh and even a
small model like birthdays will compile
for at least 10 10 minutes maybe maybe
15 minutes so when we move into bigger
models it could be much longer so we're
gonna save that time because we're gonna
keep adding those compound versions
the link in the documentation we have
like a whole guide about how the
training cache works it's really it
checks your configuration if there's
like a cached model and we are like
currently working on like making the
cash as big as possible for like the
most common like models if you are
running into situations where your model
is not cached you have the option to
either create your private cache so
there's a ways for you to define a high
invest repository which will then be
used as your personal private care so in
case you're working on like some
sensitive models or not release models
you can like really build your own
private cache for your organization or
if you think okay it might be a good
addition for the community we have on
the hiking phase Forum a dedicated
section for inferential and trainium you
can like easily open a thread please add
model XYZ
um to the cache and then we will like
work with you to to add it to the cash
to like help others like run training
fast fast on the model
that's really cool so that means like if
I'm uh like regularly training my own
model
um that like maybe on a private
repository on a hug and face Hub
um then every time I do like another uh
another training job like I'm gonna use
the compile configuration and just like
use the sweet acceleration trainer and
that's going to work for me for my model
with cash uh that's going to be private
to me
yep save time and save money because
obviously the compilation time is uh you
know is is being built
um and so um yeah it's if you train you
know if you train a hundred times you
save 100 times 10 minutes and and the
corresponding amount in dollars so yeah
I think it's it's an amazing feature
Julian we got a question from like you
said
um that's Optimum neuron work on the
sagemaker studio
so you need to run Optimum uh neuron
either on a trainum instance or an
inferencia instance
um so I think the place to run so
if you're launching your training script
from studio right or if you're running
your own stagemaker notebook inside
sagemaker studio and firing you know
training jobs and
um in inside of uh of sagemaker I mean
eventually we will have a full
integration there as well
but if you run your notebook in place on
studio
um you know it's been a while since IU
Studio I'll be honest with you
um and that might come as a surprise to
some of you
but
um I'm not sure if they have trainium
trainium darker images on on Studio I
think the instance you know the instance
available the instance is available to
Studio instances do not include training
but I could be wrong prove me wrong and
I will learn something yeah I think say
it in the comments yeah yeah I think if
like uh geranium instances are available
for like the worker Runners On Studio
where you can like execute you or run
your notebooks then of course you can
Micron Optimum lawyer on there but the
requirement is basically you want to run
on training or inferential to get any
bin any benefit from what Optimum neuron
provides like the trainium trainer with
the cache of course only works on uh AWS
accelerator since
there's like no need on a CPU to compile
the model for for training
awesome well that was that was a that
was impressive demo like you went from
zero to 100
uh just uh while we answered a few
questions
um yeah we got the answer from Matt okay
all right
Matt is a friend of trainium and instant
and influential okay thanks Matt that's
what I thought thanks Matt
foreign
Optimum neuron and how you can uh use it
to very easily and quickly and while
saving money doing it uh train models
train hiking face models leveraging uh
trainium we're gonna keep working on
this to make it easier and easier
um and uh yeah like the the benefits in
terms of time to train in terms of cost
to train uh are really really uh
impressive so hope uh hope you'll be
taking advantage of it but of course we
talked about training but that's not all
we wanted to talk about we also wanted
to talk about inference
um and uh for that yeah happy to hand it
over to to usually to tell us what's hot
in inference World let me share my
screen and I'll show you something all
right
go
[Music]
okay all right
can you confirm you you see my screen
okay
uh yeah let me add it right now okay
thank you
yep
at the same time okay take your time
take your time we can see it I guess
okay all right oh yeah yeah all right
perfect so
um so inferentia in the latest
generation which is inferential two is
re um as you can imagine a a custom chip
that's been developed by AWS
to speed up inference right AWS names
can be weird but some with sometimes but
I think with trinium and inferentia it's
pretty easy to know which is which so of
course I would encourage you to go and
check out the the inferential two page
on the AWS website and of course the
training page you can read about the the
features and see the the different sizes
and in fact in this demo I'm going to
use
I'm going to use the the smallest one
which is
INF to XL and it comes with one
inferential to accelerator
and and we can see the price for it and
that's always important right it's only
76 cents on demand price
and um and the one I'm using uh is a is
a spot instance I think
and um or I'll use the spot instance
last time I don't remember if that's the
same and uh and I was able to get 70
discount on this so uh it was just a tad
over 20 cents an hour which is honestly
crazy when you think about the you know
the amount of technology that you're
getting for 20 cents an hour
um that's that's really great so go and
read all about that
um uh again you should definitely go and
check out the uh the neuron
documentation neuron is the SDK that
lets you work with trainium and
inferential instances
so you can see all the information for
pi torch and tensorflow and how to train
and how to run inference there's a super
super cool section on the architecture
of those chips we you know we won't go
into that today but if you want to know
what those chips are and why they're
fast etc etc there's a lot of good
information there so for the hardware
Geeks in the house you you don't want to
miss this okay
so so now I have this uh I have my
instance here
so I created it just you know the usual
way
and uh and we can see that it has those
uh
um those two cores okay so one
inferentia two accelerator comes with
two cores and that's what we have here
okay
um and I'm using um I'm using uh an Ami
that includes Pi torch and everything I
need
so I didn't have to install anything
okay
and I'm using uh I'm using a couple of
demos
um from one of my repos but I have to be
honest these are really versions that I
stole from the neuron SDK and tweaked a
little bit but you know I'll post the
link to that stuff anyway if you want to
run the exact same code that I did here
so um so
we we need to do two steps right so the
first step is we need to compile the
model for inferentia too and then we can
run inference and we can run
benchmarking in fact
uh with the same model so
so the model is the model that I uh used
in a previous experiment I think I
actually trained this particular one on
trainium funny enough
so it's a pie torch it's a bird model
for multi-class classification uh it's a
model that I fine-tuned on five classes
you know star ratings from one to five
um and so combining the model is
not very difficult I think you could say
so we're not going to read all that code
but what you need to do really is you
need to import so it's a pytorch model
right so I need to import torch
I need to import torch neuron X which is
the neuron SDK for inferentia too and
what this does is it brings all the nice
torch compatible objects that will help
me accelerate and compile the model with
very little effort so the rest is just
vanilla code where I load the the
vanilla model and predict with it Etc
and I just test it out okay so this is
really just a very simple stuff
and I print out some predictions
and then okay I say well now I want to
convert this model for for the neuron
SDK right and for inferential and you
know every time I see this I I still
find it hard to believe this is the only
thing I need to do right so what this
does is it's literally going to compile
that birth model
for inferentia 2 right and all you need
to do is call the API pass the model
itself and pass a sample input which
here is just a sample a sample a
restaurant review that I wrote out there
that's it so run this runs for a couple
of minutes I've done it before there's
nothing interesting to see just gonna
it's just gonna crunch happily and then
you can save your compiled model just
like that okay so you know for lazy
folks like me this is this is perfect I
don't think you can remove anything from
those three two lines of code actually
combine the model and save it we we
actually even made it simpler uh in in
inside Optimum neuron it's part of the
the ddcli which is basically like
Optimum CLI export neuron X and then
like the model ID and that's it so you
don't need to like run through like the
python code you can like basically
execute it in your terminal get saved
your Northern model and then like run
inference on it yep so it's it's really
you know as simple as that so you don't
need to understand anything about
inferential you can take your existing
code and just you know compile and save
the model just like this okay so now we
have
um like I said I've done this before
because you know it's it takes a couple
of minutes and we don't want to wait so
we have the the saved uh compile model
here and now of course we want to test
it okay
so in Benchmark it
so in this example you know again uh
pretty much the only thing I need to do
is to import uh the the neuron SDK right
and then okay again I'm loading my model
okay just like that
and I'm predicting uh you know a
positive input a negative input just to
make sure the model is doing what I
think it should be doing okay print the
the logits
uh print results for a positive review
negative review okay just just to see
okay this model seems to work okay but I
wasn't worried too much of course the
interesting thing is I want to Benchmark
it I want to see how fast and you know
how fast it predicts and how much
throughput I can get from from
influential to and so again the neuron
SDK has this uh examples they have this
really cool Benchmark function where we
can actually load a model
uh as many times as we have uh uh as we
have course
and just create a whole bunch of threads
and predict examples okay so that's what
I'm doing here okay so I've got uh I've
got two cores so I'm going to load two
models and so the threads will the
prediction threads will run on those two
cores we're saving all the we're
Computing all the prediction times right
and so we're building a list with all
the prediction times and then
we're printing out the you know the the
50 uh there's three quartiles you know
percentiles uh p50 P95 P99 okay so very
very useful
um benchmarking function I'll steal it
again and again okay and then we print
the results so
there's more benchmarking code than
actual code here than actual machine
learning code so to speak uh what are we
really doing is okay we know how many
cores we have we're loading the models
uh as many times as we have cores and
we're just running all the predictions
through that stuff okay so now let's
just go and run this see how it goes
and here so I'm using uh I have to to be
crystal clear I'm using a batch size of
one
and I am using
um short a short sequence but in the
blog post that I'll show you after that
uh we've actually run tests on longer
sequencies so here I'm using I think
sequence lengths of 12 if I remember
correctly okay so now we here you see
the
uh you know just the unit predictions
with the with the the model that I
loaded and now it's actually running
those you know tens of thousands of
predictions on the on the two neuron
cores and uh in a you know in a couple
of uh seconds or maybe a little more
where uh where we'll actually see what
the latency is for this right so you can
place your bets
yes
while we wait we got a great question
it's like compiling between forensia
possible for all IE phase models oh yeah
well go ahead
yeah so so currently
um not yet I have to say so
um of course the hiking face Hub is not
only for Transformer models anymore so
we have a lot of more machine learning
libraries with like sklearn or like Nemo
models and but for like the transformer
models and diffuser models we are really
working heavily with the AWS team to
make all of them compatible currently
inferentia 2 was released like 10 days
ago we have support for all encoder
models and there's already some limited
support for generative models like opt
or gpt2 and within the next like I would
say like four to six weeks you will see
support for T5 for
um GPT new X for all of the I would say
like cool hot new generative models and
probably by summer you you can like use
all of them
yes waiting for that so we run a hundred
thousand predictions on those two on
those two cores we can see the
throughput is higher than 1700
predictions per second
and we can see you know I always look
I'm a pessimistic person mostly so I
always look at P99 and we can see P99 so
99 percent
of the predictions uh uh are running at
one point
26 milliseconds or faster
okay so yeah
okay no I just ran 100 000 predictions
so we're you know we're we're definitely
we're not even single low digit
milliseconds we're one point something
millisecond prediction at scale right
sustained okay
um and um on a chip well on an instance
that costs
76 cents an hour if you don't know how
to use spot
and and that you can take down to
probably 25 or 26 Cents
um per hour if you set up spot
right so I I if you want to have fun you
can actually compute the cost per
prediction
right so you you know you just take 26
Cents okay so 0.26
and you divide it by uh 17 uh you know
one thousand uh 700 400 000 blah blah
blah multiply by uh uh thirty six
hundred it's a very tiny number
I can tell you so
uh this is really great
um this I could not believe that like I
said the number when I saw it
and um and so of course the uh you know
it made us want to Benchmark things a
little more and um and actually
um Philip did a uh a lot of interesting
uh number crunching uh it's on the blog
you can you can find it I helped a
little bit but it did most of the work
and okay yeah Philip I'll let you
comment the what we see here
um
yeah yeah I think that's something I
want to add quickly like to your
benchmark which is like super critical
and always forget and so like if we
compare it to gpus a big difference that
we get for this 76 cents on demand is we
get like two accelerators so you are not
only being able to run one model we are
running two models which has a latency
of one second so if you really
yeah so you get two accelerators uh
within that instance and so the
throughput there uh is really amazing
like we're talking about like how our
work with uh Engineers working at the
hardware layer on these accelerator is
going to save the community a ton of
money like if you're running an encoder
model like in production today like you
gotta run and test this thing out
because you're gonna save blogs
absolutely so I'll just take over while
Philip yes
I don't know like streaming up close
then I opened again so thanks thanks for
covering yeah it's like it is really
amazing that you have like two and even
if you like go to bigger in Frontier
instances you have like more calls
available meaning more models in
parallel meaning more throughput which
is like really crazy for for the price
you get and like as Julian has shown it
here like the green green bar you can
see is like inferentia too and you can
see it's like always by far like the
lowest and something we we should
definitely mention like for GPU we
didn't like run the inference in mixed
Precision so the GPU like bar will drop
down if you like improve or like
optimize your model for GPU but Julian
has shown it to you that the conversion
from like CPU to a Neuron model it's
like one call for GPU you might need
some expertise on how to do it you might
need to hire people on how to do it for
influential you really like run this one
line or even like a CLI command and then
you are ready to use and so and like
save money and have like Fast inference
yeah and you in this Benchmark so we use
the the G5 uh the G5 instance which um
you know which is a a good a good GPU
instance it has an A10 A10 GPU which a
lot of AWS customers use to run uh to
run Transformer inference and deep
learning inference so it's not it's
definitely not a toy instance it's
actually the preferred instance for uh
for a lot of inference workloads uh with
with Transformers and I mean no
disrespect but you know it's it's
honestly it's blown away right so yeah
if you even if you optimize which is
certainly going to be harder than you
know copying and pasting the the one
line that I uh that I showed you there
um you know I don't think you're gonna
get to to one millisecond and you can
see it scales very nicely even with
longer sequences
um so um and and I think you have an
example for the the vision Transformer
as well
um which you know which is equally good
um and um and so yeah three millisecond
latency for the for the vision
Transformer at this cost you know always
think about cost performance people are
obsessed about speed but you know it's
um speed is one thing but cost
performance is generally what matters
more
um in in an Enterprise setting so so
here I think it's very very hard to beat
very hard it was an amazing demo thank
you so much Julian thank you Philip
thank you cast uh so I say that it was a
an error on my end to make this an hour
we wanted to make it 30 minutes and I
guess that was for science
um I asked Hagin Chad it was the hugging
chat episode right so we got a little
bit chatty I will try to make these uh
better uh as we go uh if you have any
comments on uh this uh episode and you
would like to see more or you should
tell us really like what you guys should
stop uh tell us uh and uh yeah thank you
so much for joining
um yes Jade Brown this is recorded we're
gonna post it on YouTube and it's going
to be available on demand probably at
the same URL uh shortly thank you thank
you everybody thank you Eve see you next
time David thank you everybody and keep
rocking